last week sima liu was really upset to
watch the unexpected last episode kim
convenience
air he has much more to celebrate this
week first off today is his birthday so
happy birthday uh he turned 32 today
and marvel dropped the teaser for his
superhero
debut shang chi and the legend of the
ten rings
yeah so see me wrote on instagram
whoever said that you can only receive
presents on your birthday you know i
never saw myself as a hero
of my own story growing up i struggled
to find any asian characters on screen
and there are fewer still that made me
truly proud of my heritage
it's absolutely insane to think that in
just over four months we'll have a
marvel studios movie
featuring an almost entirely asian cast
it's full of nuance and dimensionality
is more than just a movie it is a
celebration of our culture and a
rallying cry
for the forgotten the unseen and the
overlooked it is a reminder to take up
space to stand tall
and to be unapologetically ourselves of
course
it's also going to deliver superhero
action like you've never
seen before here's the trailer
son it's time for you to take your place
by my side
[Music]
[Music]
who you really are
how are you
oh god hold on everybody
[Applause]
we make a good team
[Laughter]
lindsay says yes to more representation
and diversity at the forefront
how how it should have been all along
guys is loving the score
and tony says we all have a right to see
ourselves as superheroes kenji says this
movie looks great
what's your action i know i'm excited
you know this is what it's all about
this is the excitement this has changed
and it's
it's about time this happens and i can't
wait for it and simulia is perfect for
this
it looks like it's going to be fun i
mean his character is known as the
master of kung fu
and brother hand and a lot of people
know this character so
uh for him to bring it to life i can't
wait i can't wait for my kids to watch
this it's going to be an exciting
roller coaster to watch it yeah chad
[ __ ] says wow looks like a great
movie francis aquafina yes alice's the
trail looks great
yeah um nelson's they're only good at
remaking copying foreign movies
i mean i'm sure there's influences from
asian cinema in there as well
now carlos is gonna have a full like
breakdown of the trailer because he's
like the comic book guy so we're not the
comic book
uh people but no it looks like super
like super fun to
like to watch this and yeah i just think
about representation like the last
episode of the
falcon the winter soldier that came out
on friday it was episode five
they finally got around to like
addressing sam having the shield
the first person has been pretty
pointless yeah but but even
sam had uh you know moments about
taking on the captain america shield you
know being a black man in america where
you know black people aren't treated the
best in america like you know do i want
to be
captain america do i know do i want to
represent this country so it's a really
interesting part
of that story it's just the fact that
we're getting these kind of stories now
in superhero and in marvel it's just
like amazing to see that like
like just the progression that's
happened with yours yeah with black
panther in that like it's amazing that
this is the direction of marvel's going
isn't it crazy grab that it's all
happening like it you know
if you think back and you're just like
it's 20 21 and we're
this is like the exciting news that is
happening and it should have happened so
long ago and uh i can't wait
all of it is just kind of coming
together and representation is finally
being accepted and simulated just
bringing this to life
i i can't wait for it this is going to
be an epic moment
i mean look at that look look that's
just pure power there look at that
is that leather he's wearing leather i
can't i can't fully see but see
and watching the episode of the falcon
with the soldier like the idea of
representation and like
people think this is all like frivolous
stuff like no it matters the fact that
you know
every walk of life is going to see you
know a black man being captain america
they're going to see simulator playing
this role so it's like
yeah like all this stuff matters just
everything becomes more acceptable right
you just get used to seeing different
races and different roles and different
walks of life so it's like yeah
this is the way things should be going
that's that's that's what it is it's
about our kids being able to see
themselves reflected on television on
social media i mean
i didn't have that growing up being a
south asian girl that was very rare to
see anyone of my skin tone on television
or
or in magazines or anywhere so knowing
that the next generation
is going to be able to say this is
normal is
pretty exciting and that you know when
you think about marvel movies and you
think about superhero movies and
uh how much of an impact that really has
it's it's important
so it's going to be pretty good what's
wrong with your earpiece are you
i thought someone's knocking the door
but i think there's like construction
going on upstairs
this is the homework sorry i was having
an emotional moment there
and you're you're worried about the
oh but let's fill this if paul says okay
graham the disrespect
to the falcon and the winter soldier
will not be tolerated your inability to
see a point
in the first four episodes reveals your
explicit bias what's my bias paul
but they've been chasing down the the
super serum that creates these uh
whatever the heightened soldiers it
hasn't been that interesting the end of
and the end game was sam getting the
shield i want to see that story i don't
want to see them chasing around some
serum
so they finally got that in episode 5. i
don't know what my bias is paul
but i'm sorry that i have a bias